hello folks and welcome to rational
science
why are we rational well because
just about everybody out there is
irrational
and people say well bill that's just
your opinion
you know what's rational to you is
irrational to me
well that's not the way we do it in
science the way we do it in science we
have to define these
key adjectives find out what they mean
and so uh here we have a set of criteria
for the word
for the adjective right rational or
irrational in this case
uh treating concepts as objects number
one
you know reification concretization uh
what people do is they turn
energy into a physical object and then
they start
transferring it and they turn mass into
a physical object and they start pushing
it
they push the mass they stretch the
field they accelerate the charge
all those are concepts i mean charge
what is charge uh
what is it 1.6 times 10 to the minus 19
coulombs
is that what you're accelerating so uh
so yeah it's when you reify
uh concepts and turn them into objects
that's when we have a problem and that's
what mathematical physics does
mathematical physics is in the uh
in the business of um redefining
concepts
and in great measure because they don't
consider that the mathematical
physicists
they don't consider that as part of
science they don't get serious part of
physics they say that's on the other
side of campus
you know you got to go to a philosophy
of science or some
or philosophy or whatever uh to do that
and uh it's the other way around really
you know
what we understand how this universe
works we want to understand how the
invisible universe works mother nature's
invisible universe
we want to know how she does her you
know her tricks or magic tricks her
invisible
intangible tricks that's what we want to
find out and of course you'll never find
an answer to that
in mathematical physics because as mr
feynman nobel prize of what is 1965
said they've given up on that
[Laughter]
yeah no kid they could figure it out so
they gave up
okay so what does uh mathematical
physics propose and what does everybody
out there
essentially propose well for the last 10
000 years they've been proposing the
same thing
okay maybe not that far back i'm
exaggerating a little bit but here it is
in a nutshell uh what is light
well they say it's a bunch of flowing
particles
and they're not really particles i mean
they're not core puzzles like
newton thought of particles they're not
dust particles they're not little balls
they're quantum particles
what's a quantum particle quantum
particle is a magical particle
it has all these magical properties in
other words it's not
a pr a particle at all and just when
you're gonna touch it just when you're
gonna grab it
it turns into a wave you call it wave
particle duality
and you say okay turn into a wave what's
a wave
and wave what you see there it's a bunch
of vectors
mathematical vectors what's a vector it
has uh
magnitude and direction what the
mathematicians have done
is they illustrate vectors mathematical
vectors
all you're seeing there is magnitude and
direction you know think of the number 5
with
some direction i don't know and they're
moving
well that's scary that's very scary when
that happens you know it
makes you tremble and yeah this is what
everybody out out there deals with
and uh so when you say hey this is all
irrational they say well again go to the
other side of campus
and talk to them not to us okay because
this
is part of the physical interpretation
that's what we're attacking because
that's what physics is about or was
supposed to be about at least
and they stopped doing that a very long
time ago they gave
gave up on that like uh finance said
okay so they come up with this this is
their atom
and it's the ridiculous atom that niels
bohr and
rutherford uh concocted
essentially and then was carried on by
everybody else
and what's irrational about that is as
you can see there's a little bead a
blue one going around and it jumps
to a different orbital or different uh
energy level
then it pops back up okay so it goes
from one region to the other
and the only issue that you gotta ask
here is why doesn't that beat fly away
spontaneously
what keeps it bound to the red proton
this is the atom the hydrogen atom right
what keeps it bound to the proton that's
all you gotta answer if you can't answer
that question you can't even start your
presentation we will
remove the microphone from the front of
your mouth
we won't let you talk because you can't
even start your presentation you don't
have an object with which
we can follow your presentation see they
explain
one what you see at the bottom they
explain electricity with that
they also explain ionization
they explain quantum jumping they all
explain with this atom
and at the end of their presentation
they say oh by the way that was in our
atom
[Laughter]
we cannot imagine our atom that's what
they tell you and so
yeah what you see is is uh
what you get and what you get is not
what
is in other words what you're supposed
to do if you're a proponent of that atom
that planetary atom which everybody 100
of people
use this and illustrate this don't take
my word for it just google
uh you know in the images the quantum
atom that's what you'll see
you won't see another one and you say
well why does the bead fly away
that's all you got to answer it's that
simple you can't answer that question
you can't start your presentation you've
got
nothing to share with the world
and um here is uh
the carbon atom i showed the other day
this gives you an idea here
uh of the more sophisticated atom
they'll teach you in college
and what do you see you see all these
little flies in there those are the
beads the electron beads
and they can't escape the balloon
because those balloons are like regions
that somehow hold them back these are
the orbitals
as they call them a bunch of orbits and
you say what what are those balloons
and they'll say no those are not
balloons so what are they how can they
is that a fence i mean does that
prohibit does that impede
uh does that forbid the um the bead from
flying away
physically and of course uh they
treat that mathematically they're not
going to treat it physically because
they have no physical interpretation for
for those uh regions and you go
if you go look it up i don't take my
word for it look it up on youtube and
you'll find that all people who explain
these orbitals
they'll explain it with balloons they
tie all these balloons like clowns do
you know and
they say well this is what the orbit the
p orbital and the s orbital and so on
and you say well are are the orbitals
balloons and they say well no you're not
supposed to take that literally this is
an analogy
then why doesn't the flip bead fly away
it's just as simple as that if you can't
explain that you you can't introduce the
orbital just at random
and say oh i'm going to introduce an
orbital just for the sake
of my you know my presentation you can't
do this
it's ad hoc what do we propose instead
well we propose
something a little different this is how
the atom is constructed really it's a
physical entity not like in
mathematical physics which is an
abstraction we have two
physical threads and they twine around
like dna
and they form this rope which is going
to be the mediator of light
and they converge upon our atom okay you
can see there they converge upon the
edge of the atom
and that red line at that red curve line
that's the electron shell
it's con weaved by every rope coming
from
every atom in the universe all atoms in
the universe
are physically connected one thread goes
through the center of the atom
and from every atom in the universe we
have one donation one
thread and that forms that proton star
and the star is encapsulated by a uh
membrane which we call the electron
shell and here on the bottom left you
see
uh quick 2d and 3d versions
of what what we're proposing okay
so that's in a nutshell our atom what
can we explain with this atom now we
showed you the physical object you have
no
if you have questions well you can ask
about them but at least you know what
we're presenting and we're not going to
say well that's not our atom no that is
our atom
okay so what you saw is what you get
okay that's what you want
okay you don't have to believe it you're
just supposed to understand it
okay so uh so what is uh light
well light is this the atom expands and
contracts
okay you have the 2d and the 3d version
there
and what it does is torque the rope and
the torsion along the rope is what we
call light
that's why light is so fast because
light is not a 2d
transverse wave that goes up and down as
fresnel
said in the 19th century and james
maxwell
no what light is is a torsion a 3d
torsion along a physical mediator okay
and you may say well i don't know about
that but
one thing we can explain with that is
speed
why is light so fast and i made a little
um
uh i call it my rope machine it's a
torsion machine
and i took it to one of my presentations
i don't know if i presented this in the
past but let me just
show you this okay if i can find it here
uh where is it here
and uh this is my torsion machine
it's a rope that's twirling
and the signal goes in both directions
in opposite directions simultaneously
and this is going a very slow speed but
light
really you know a torsion just is the
fastest thing you can imagine
it really is in fact i try to film once
uh i put two clothespins
on uh on a rope and i with a camera
trying to film this and i touch one to
see if i could see
when the other one moved it's like
instantaneous
you could try it at home you know always
in the presence of a relativist okay
because
dangerous experiment okay and what else
can we explain what we can explain
uh why light is also travels always in a
at a constant speed okay and here it is
uh when you shine light through a prism
okay what you're gonna get on the other
side is
different colors what are colors well
they are different link lengths of
the rope and
[Music]
you can see the equation there the wave
equation c equals frequency times
wavelength
okay and when you increase the frequency
the wavelength goes
down and vice versa in other words
they're inversely
related okay inversely proportional and
um
and so all we do with the rope is
just exchange frequency for wavelength
there's no no way
n never an uh an increase in speed
here let me give you a for instance okay
uh here you have a rope
get in the center here okay and you see
what
uh maybe three links there okay
and for that amount of rope that's
between my two uh
fists and those represent the atoms
right okay what happens when you torque
the rope
at a higher frequency right we're gonna
get higher frequency here okay
and now we have what more links but each
link is shorter
c equals frequency times wavelength is
the equation of a rope what have we done
we've
shortened the the wavelength you know in
this case the
link length and what we have is more
links more frequency c equals frequency
times wavelength
uh which is um
the wave equation why you know the speed
of light they say in a vacuum no it's
always
is the equation of a rope okay that's
what it is so we can explain all these
with a rope
model okay and it's a physical model
hopefully mother nature does her things
out there with
physical things and not with abstract
mathematical concepts such as energy
and fields okay so this is where the
problem is these people are using
concepts
and then they say well we didn't mean it
yeah no kidding you didn't mean it okay
okay so summarizing here's the
difference between the rest of the world
and us
and uh what these people do is they
[Music]
have all this ether particles
and when they want to use a wave they
say well it's the vibration
of the ether so there you have your wave
it's what is it the
vibration of those particles what do we
propose instead we propose that all
atoms in the universe
are physically interconnected they are
physically
interconnected what interconnects them
the electromagnetic rope that binds any
two atoms
and which uh becomes the atoms you know
so it's it's a long string it's a single
thread in all of space that's all it is
and that thread
moves through every atom in the universe
and
builds the atoms and builds the ropes
that interconnect them
that's the model okay so you can see
we're a little different than everybody
else out there
okay and uh yeah the ether
is what everybody else uses and you
don't have to take my word for it let's
let's go with a little bit of authority
which is what people believe out there
and here's authority okay
uh mr laughlin nobel prize of 1998
and what did he say he says the modern
concept of the vacuum of space
confirmed every day by experiment is a
relativistic
ether okay but we do not call it this
because it is
taboo yeah it's the ether i mean what is
space time spice
space time is a bunch of events right
and each event what is an event it's a
point in space time it's a
tongue twister it goes back and forth
right and so um
when you take all these points and put
them together you have a sandbox right
and uh what is a sandbox well it's a
ether that's the ether so the ether is a
sandbox
but somehow they have all these
particles just moving
okay and uh okay that's the ether and
we've never abandoned ether we've
had the ether for the last three
thousand years
no one has ever abandoned ether uh
robert hooke used it uh
huygens used it newton all these folks
used the ether they were all
believers in the ether that there was
this this background of particles
and it was waving one newton said it
went straight
the other guy said it was waving but the
point is they all relied on the ether
and today there's no difference quantum
calls it the ether they call it the
false vacuum they
they talk about particles in coming in
from space
separating into positive negative
particles recombining going back
to form nothing space
just uh magic pure magic pure
irrationality